press secretary circle back jensaki
she tried to warn us about sippy cup joe
she tried to warn us about the
never-ending
ever so confusing mumbling and bumbling
and stumbling joe biden
all the way back during the campaign uh
joey sippy cup if you're watching
if you're up past your night night time
uh
if you haven't had your warm milky in
your little sippy cup
well this is the message that you're
projecting to the rest of the world and
don't take my word for it
just listen to your own white house
press secretary
there have been a number of moments
where even those of us who have
affection for
vice president biden think what on earth
is happening right now from
from extremely from charlotte
one another line going from
in florida down to tampa that
is a major factor
we don't see that that look so the best
way to get something done
if you if it holds near and dear to you
that you uh
like to be able to
sucky sees what we see but now she's
just hiding it that's joe sippy cup with
the
presidential seal so ask yourself the
serious part of this what do you think
vladimir putin
president xi the ayatollahs and iran the
rest of the world of thinking when they
see
this by the way they're not being
influenced by the media mob
and those protecting joe they see it for
what it is
america we do need strong forceful
decisive leadership the world needs it
we need
clear cogent common sense thinking
uh but what we're getting from joe is
the exact opposite
a never-ending stream of stumbles
mumbles and outright incoherence
and by the way what is the rest of the
world thinking when they see
zero experience hunter traveling all
over the world
profiting off his father's diplomacy
cutting deals he has zero qualifications
to be involved in
why because joe quid pro quo and zero
experience hunter
well they have a lot of explaining to do
tonight
about the biden family syndicate the
corrupt syndicate
because a breaking story from hunter's
laptop miranda divine new york post
and it reveals that joe biden himself
back in
april of 2015 he appears to have met
with his son's ukrainian russian
kazakhstan business partners had a nice
dinner in washington
while he was vice president and
according to records on
hunter's hard drive from hell well now
as we previously reported the day after
this dinner
wow hunter got an email from an
executive at barista holdings
about an opportunity and thanking hunter
for the opportunity to meet his father
while he was vice president and get this
hunter appears to have used his role
on the board of the world food program
as a pretext to introduce his business
associates
to daddy quote the reason for the dinner
is ostensibly to discuss food security
hunter row
before adding quote dad will be there
but keep that between us for now
thanks uh now joe biden is on record
saying
over and over and over again that he
never
once not a single time ever discussed
his son's foreign business dealings with
him
really joe do you stand by that take a
look
mr vice president how many times have
you ever spoken to your son
about his overseas business dealings
i've never spoken my son about his
overseas ministers i have never
discussed
with my son or my brother or anyone else
anything having to do with their
businesses period do you stand by your
statement that you did not discuss
any of your son's overseas business yes
i stand by that statement
yes i stand by that statement well
he's lying now it does explain something
doesn't it
why would a vice president ever say
you're not getting a billion dollars
unless you fire a ukrainian prosecutor
or would a vice president want a
ukrainian
prosecutor fired because that was the
prosecutor investigating his zero
experienced son
being paid millions now add this
explosive new development to what we
already know
it was exposed first by peter schweitzer
senator grassley senator johnson and
others
but it's about time we get actual
answers actual transparency
from joe biden imagine if it was donald
trump we have a lot more coming up but
speaking of and demanding straight
answers we do turn
to our other top story and that's
surrounding you know dr
doom and gloom flip-flop fauci who
continues to play koi on how
your taxpayer dollars were spent at the
wuhan lab of virology and whether they
were used as part of what is called
gain of function research he was grilled
by senator kennedy of louisiana
on all of this yesterday take a look you
gave them money and you said
don't do gain the function research
correct and they said we won't
correct and you
have no way of knowing whether they did
or not except you trust them
is that right well we generally
always trust the grantee to do what they
say and you look at the results have you
ever had a grantee lie to you
i cannot guarantee that a grantee has
not lied
to us because you never know
the pastor said oh they we never did
such a thing now maybe i don't know
anyway the bite administration still
reluctant to ever be
critical of china at all and now they're
still deferring to the
corrupt wh on a probe into the origins
of this virus
but we're now learning that the senate
has approved a bill that will now
require
the byte administration to declassify
intelligence
on the origins of the coven 19 virus
that killed
how many people worldwide how many
americans
and a top u.s general is sounding that
alarm china's coveted cover-up is
hampering efforts
into getting to the bottom of where this
started and how to prevent it from ever
happening again
remember only a few short months ago
that even
mentioning the lab leak theory got you
written off by
everybody in the media mob and the
democrats and big
tech as a conspiracy theorist
just for asking the logical questions
but now by the way
the corrupt left-wing institutions
they're now doing a complete 180
and they're in total damage control mode
for example facebook
oh how nice of them they finally ended
their ban on posts
about the lab league theory
acknowledging that maybe it wasn't a
conspiracy theory at all
just like the new york times is doing
fake news cnn is doing the washington
post is doing
but still despite growing evidence
supporting the lab league theory
well some in the media mobs still don't
want to ever talk about it
and they don't want to be able to ask
legitimate questions for example
fake news reporter over at the new york
times tweeting quote
someday we will stop talking about the
lab league theory and maybe
even admit its racist roots
okay but alas that day is not here yet
oh maggie haberman blaming donald trump
i guess they really at the new york
times wanting to get real answers
about a virus that has killed millions
worldwide that's racist
the destructive democratic agenda
doesn't stop there because the biden
administration
they're now trying to jam through that
guy as the atf nominee
alcohol tobacco firearms david shipman
is his name
no friend of the second amendment in our
constitution
stumped repeatedly yesterday when asked
to define
well you want to ban assault weapons and
you don't want
any police and schools protecting our
kids well what is
an assault weapon can you define it
watch
do you believe in banning assault
weapons i do sir
okay define assault weapons
assault weapons would be something that
members of congress would define
well how do you define it you're going
to be running the agency
senator i think this is a good question
if i am um
confirmed as atf director um i got 35
seconds left
define it for me would you please sir um
what's an assault weapon yeah senator
um the bill uh to ban assault what
happens is what is your thousands of
pages there's no way i could define an
assault weapon
you don't have you're going to run this
agency and you don't have a definition
of assault weapon
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else